what's up
[Music]
is
the european climate pact is here
no ambition too small
magalayna
will you join us
[Music]
[Music]
will you join us
good morning everybody and welcome to
the launch event of the european climate
pact
my name is betrayed rios and i will be
the presenter for today's program
let's have a look at the agenda we will
have with us today
activists musicians citizens like you
and me and even chefs to talk about
climate change
and we will be joined as well by the
executive vice president for the
european green deal
franz timmermans who will be answering
your questions
we also have with us artist alice garan
who will be
graphic recording today's event hello
alex how are you doing
also you will be able to find
translation in german
french italian spanish police portuguese
greek
that swedish and hungarian but before
i would like to know a little bit more
about you now i'm going to ask you
to go to your browser and type slido.com
or download the app you should be able
to see
the event code on your screen it's eu
climate pact
i want you to tell me where are you
joining from
i'm going to give a little bit of time
for you to join
slowly tell me where you're joining from
which part of europe
maybe beyond europe
france i see friends coming up i'm sure
there's people germany as well a lot of
people coming from germany i see
see belgium greece italy
austria spain
france italy again a lot of oceans a lot
of german people and french people a lot
of austrians and
spanish netherlands as well
wow a lot of people from all across
europe this is amazing
i'm going to ask you a second question
now so bear with me
what have you done today for the
environment
let me know maybe you took a shorter
shower
or you had a bio breakfast
let me know what have you done today for
the environment
maybe you bike to work today do you took
public transport
i see someone took a bag and breakfast
um took a ride with the bike
lovely thank you so much for your
answers now
if there is something about climate
change you've always wanted to ask to mr
zimmerman's but never had the chance
now it is the time we will be collecting
the questions via slido as well but if
you don't have any burning question
or you see one that you really like you
can vote your favorite too
because we will collecting the most
voted ones and mr zimmerman himself
will be answering them live in a few
minutes
but before we dive in let's take a
minute i want you to be comfortable now
and i want you to bear with me i know
we've been confined at home for a very
long time
and we haven't had the chance to travel
but i want you to think about
that place on earth that took your
breath away
i want you to think about the feeling of
fulfillment when you go for a hike
and you reach the peak the beautiful
view
the fresh air i want you to think about
the first swim of the summer
the water on your skin the smell of the
sea breeze
even i want you to think about how
wonderful it is to see the seasons
change
even by just looking through your window
well
all that is in danger due to climate
change now the good thing
is that today we will be talking about
all the many ways in which
me you as citizens can contribute to the
fight against climate change
that is what the european climate pact
is all about
it is about taking action but doing it
together it is about spreading knowledge
and raising awareness
it is about joining forces building
bridges helping each other to find
a way to contribute the karma pact is
about
inspiring people and because no action
is too small
and together we can make it we we're
going to explain to you
how you can join let's start
the first goal of the european climate
pact is raising awareness
today we have with us three very special
guests whose stories
i hope will give you a better idea of
the need for climate action
now when he became aware of the need to
fight climate change he was at her mind
to find out
what he could do about it some might
dice to eat less
or no meat join a protest ride a bike
is timber founded climate science an
organization that works to provide
real-life long-term solutions to climate
change
but he will tell you all about it
through this video
hello firstly i want to thank the
european commission
for the opportunity to give the opening
statement at the launch event of the
european climate pact
initiatives like this one are crucial
because emissions reductions in one year
don't mean anything if emissions go up
again the next year
what we need are solutions that allow us
to turn
into a zero emission society forever
this is exactly what i focus on there is
a lot of confusion
about what's important to achieving this
goal but the numbers are pretty clear
over 90 percent of all greenhouse gas
emissions
come from energy and agriculture so we
should unite
and we should focus on these two issues
when i first realized how big of a
problem climate change is
i immediately wanted to do something i
wanted to act so i went and googled how
to solve climate change and
a lot of the answers that were listed
were things like drive less
fly less eat less meat and use a bamboo
toothbrush and so on
the issue with that is that even if we
all do it assume everyone does this and
we managed to reduce emissions by
50 which would be a remarkable
achievement
we'd still have climate change it would
just happen
a bit later because what used to take
one year now takes two years to emit
so those are great steps but they're not
a solution in the long term
what's more if we want to give everyone
a fair and equitable life
with the luxurious comparably luxurious
things
that we can call our living standards in
europe
we have to expect emissions to rise well
that's
unless we manage to develop solutions in
energy and agriculture
that allow us to live the life we do now
but do so sustainably to bring all the
topics relevant to this monumental
change under one roof
i co-founded climate science climate
science is a nonprofit organization
that creates and distributes educational
resources on solutions to climate change
with the help of 30 young scientists and
a lot of illustrators animators
reviewers
and authors we were able to condense the
complexity
of problems and solutions relating to
climate change into courses
children's books youtube videos and much
more
because not all of us have 30 scientists
available to them
i would like to summarize in a few
sentences why this
work has turned me from a reasonably
pessimistic
person regarding climate change to a
cautiously optimistic one
we are seeing commitments and
initiatives from all around the world
while those alone mean very little they
are coupled with technological
innovation and policy change
so when we track short-term progress on
climate change i don't like to look at
emissions on a year-to-year basis
because we need to get to zero slight
reductions don't mean much
what we should be looking at is the
progress we're making towards
having the tool set both on the
technology and policy side that it will
take
to get to zero emissions and we are
making progress on that front
for example the price of new build solar
pv has dropped by over 95 percent over
the last few decades
similarly there has been a lot of
tremendous work in electrifying
transport and some other sectors
mainly through batteries and hopefully
maybe soon through hydrogen
there's work across the world on many
many of these different sub problems and
that's really encouraging especially
because policy change and initiatives
are coming with it
we're seeing major commitments of course
here from the eu as well as from china
and many other places around the world
that's what turns me into an optimist
but it's important to
keep in mind that none of this progress
just
happens it's people
it's people's time people's work
people's ideas
people's initiatives that create this
change
we need to be those innovators and
change makers and we need to fund
those innovators and change makers that
is how we're going to get to a long-term
solution to climate change it's going to
require a lot of perseverance
there is no button anyone can press to
solve the problem it doesn't exist
but if we work together and if we form
communities of innovators and we make
sure that people have the support they
need
to do the work and create the change
that they can
i am convinced we will be able to turn
the climate crisis
into a climate challenge and i will be
able to tackle
the climate challenge and live a life
that is fair and equitable
and do so sustainably i hope the
community around the european climate
pact
will represent this viewpoint of trying
to
persevere and deal with the full
complexity of the problem
i'm thankful that i get to be a part of
this journey and i hope you enjoy the
rest of the event
thank you and definitely because the
european climate pact is all about
people action i hope that we can all
become climate optimist
after today thank you eric he is
considered one of the best chefs in the
world and was included in the top 100
most
influential people by the time magazine
in 2019.
maybe if i tell you that he runs austria
francescana one of the best restaurants
in the world do you know who i'm talking
about
but what you might not know is that he's
very much committed to ending food waste
and ensuring a sustainable ethical food
system
please welcome chef massimo batura
welcome everyone to the european
climate pact lounge event and thank you
president
ursula von der lion and executive vice
president
franz timmermans for bringing us
all together in 1935 antonio gramsci
wrote
culture is not having a stockpile of
information
but the capacity to understand the
complexity of life
culture is the place we keep sacred
it's our relationship with the people
around us
someone who has culture has the deep
understanding of themselves and
feels connected to others
i had the good fortune to live the life
i always dream of most
likely because i made a choice
34 years ago and follow my
art not my ad and choose an unlikely
career path
based on the passion for the kitchen
a few years ago there come a moment when
i realized that i needed
to take a step back from the technically
culinary revolution
that had defined the first 10 years of a
21st
century i began looking outside
our kitchens our restaurants and into
the arena of the everyday life
and i did not see the technically
culinary revolution
create better food systems what i did
see
was food waste and loss and a lack
of a long vision for the future of food
after receiving so much from the
culinary world
i felt the need to give back to the
community
to share my vision of what nourished the
planet
could mean i thought perhaps through
culture
not technique we chef could represent
more
than the sum of our recipes
and this is how a different kind of
culinary revolution
a humanistic culinary revolution
starting taking shape in our minds in
our kitchen
and in our actions this is our food for
soul a model to put the fight against
food waste
and social isolation on the front lines
began this is how we defined a new way
to feed those in need through a specific
attention to beauty
and art to create human connection
during lockdown in our home but
connected with the world
we decide to create kitchen quarantine
75 evenings of cooking together
with my family become an exercise
in sharing our passions our fears
our tradition and some culinary lessons
with the outside world during the
lockdown
we have isolated in our apartment in
modena
we share the profound joy and deep
values of
cooking at dome with family around the
world
while our volunteers in terre fatorio
were preparing packaging and delivering
meals
to the most fragile sectors
of our society the fragile souls
today in light of the global pandemic we
are beginning to understand
the value of this humanistic revolution
we have the ability to create a more
sustainable
and equitable food system through a
focus
on the power of beauty the value of
hospitality
and the quality of the ideas
when i have doubt about my ability to
affect
change i'm encouraged by the conceptual
artist joseph boyce
who proclaim in every public art project
we are the revolution not me
we all together so i invite
all to participate and join us
because all action will trigger positive
changes
and help us achieve climate naturally by
2050 join us together
we will make it
how important is culture as well in
fighting climate change who would have
thought
i definitely feel more optimistic now we
can do it together
now she is a climate scientist working
on energy efficiency
but beyond her work she is heavily
involved in youth engagement
for the energy transition she's actually
one of the founding members of the
european youth
energy network and a local activist for
the un
sustainable development goals advocating
for sustainable affordable clean
energy in this video luciana mio will
explain to you why
youth action across borders across
europe is
so incredibly important to fight climate
change
good morning ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to the launch of the european
climate pact
my name is luciana mu and i represent
the european youth energy network an
initiative that seeks to empower young
people to lead the european energy
transition
and i am privileged to share with you
today some thoughts on the role of young
people in driving meaningful climate
action
personally i grew up in romania and
emigrated to the united kingdom 10 years
ago
since then i received my phd in energy
efficiency i worked for the uk
parliament
organized the world's largest youth
energy forum developed a low-carbon beer
and communicated science through poetry
amongst other things so
i am pretty much your average
run-of-the-mill millennial and i pale in
comparison to many others
which is why i'm here today to tell you
about the countless young people who are
changing the game when it comes to
climate action
and what the climate pact can do and
what it must do to support them in their
efforts
youth action is about more than activism
indeed the value of young people lies in
many traits that make them great assets
for europe's climate ambitions such as
collaboration
action orientation and vision firstly by
being collaborative young people are a
huge resource for breaking out of silo
thinking and into systems thinking which
is crucial for driving meaningful
climate action
indeed this is the story of the european
youth energy network young people from
across europe identifying the siloed
nature of youth engagement with the
european energy transition
and working with the european commission
to try to improve this
in our short history we've tried to
break down barriers
co-creating the first ever european
youth energy day putting the youth voice
in the same room with high level
decision makers like
executive vice president of the green
deal franz timmermans
and seeking to connect youth-led
energy-focused organizations across
europe
by being action-oriented secondly youth
raise ambitions when it comes to climate
action
we are very loud about its urgency and
we understand its complexity
we know that the prospects for climate
action are vastly different even just
across the european continent
we know of the intersections of climate
action with future jobs
and education and health care and peace
and youth-led european climate action is
deeply rooted in this knowledge
for example visha gerard for
sustainability a youth-led initiative
focusing on the specific
issues of sustainability integration in
central and eastern europe
yes europe working to ensure that future
energy leadership is both cross-border
and multi-disciplinary young innovators
on climate kicks greenhouse program
developing interdisciplinary solutions
for climate change mitigation and
adaptation
just to name a few examples
thirdly youth have a different vision of
the future
they have new standards of what is
acceptable and they live by them
they own fewer cars they invest more in
sustainable portfolios
they seek out effective altruism they
found projects to revolutionize the way
we live in our environments
increased ambition commitment and
awareness are pivotal objectives of the
climate pact and it is clear that young
people
are instrumental in carrying these
objectives forward through their own
heightened awareness and commitment
so young people are primed for driving
climate action at an unprecedented pace
so what can the climate pact
do to unlock this action to answer this
question
i'd like to draw a parallel think of an
energy resource
to use it we generally start by
attaching a value to it which allows us
to then access it develop it and harness
it
what if we think about youth potential
like an
energy resource we may start to ask
ourselves some tough questions
how much are we actually valuing youth
are we accessing its full potential with
our current engagement mechanisms
can we be better at developing youth or
are we stuck in outdated ideas
of what is needed to prepare them for
the future how well are we harnessing
their power are we channeling it to the
core of our decision making or are we
treating it as auxiliary power
and most importantly are we taking for
granted that the energy of youth is
renewable
are we forgetting that they too can
become jaded adults
the climate pack gives us the
opportunity to answer these questions
and to raise the bar when it comes to
harnessing youth potential
we can value youth fully by legitimizing
the unique contribution of youth-led
movements to meaningful climate action
and giving these initiatives visibility
and
funding by increasing our cooperation we
can further engage
youth especially those young people who
are not yet engaged with climate action
we can be innovative about developing
our youth focusing as educators and
employers on the multi-disciplinary
knowledge and skills that will be key to
leading future climate action
and we can do much more in harnessing
the power of youth
as businesses by creating meaningful
employment in the sustainability sector
and empowering young people to become
green front runners in all organizations
as governments by co-creating knowledge
and solutions on climate with young
people
as the horizon europe mission for
climate adaptation does with citizens
and finally as citizens by collaborating
with young people in our climate action
and ensuring that we speak for future
generations as well as for ourselves
but most importantly the climate pact
gives us the opportunity to ensure that
the energy of young people is renewable
when it comes to climate
action because climate change is not
only the greatest challenge of our time
it will be the greatest challenge of
times yet to come
youth today and tomorrow will need to
enhance and accelerate
existing climate action efforts so i
leave you with this thought
by investing in youth now we recruit the
passion
leadership commitment and innovation
necessary to achieve our climate-packed
pledges
but we also unlock a huge resource for
taking these pledges ever further
with ever more ambition thank you very
much for your attention
mel sibo muslimesque
thank you to china passion leadership
commitment that's definitely something
that we need to the european climate
pact
very powerful inspiring messages to a
story this morning
now let me recall you that you can ask
your questions to executive vice
president
uh for the european green deal from
zimmerman's with joining us
this morning in the studio thank you so
much for being here today with us it's
my pleasure
now there is something that i have asked
our public this morning and is what have
they done today
to fight climate change and i was
wondering executive vice president what
have you done today for the environment
well today i mean it's early days today
um first of all um i've come here
with an electric car my service car is
now an electric car which is
a small contribution but it's already a
lot better
and then when i had breakfast we made
sure that we
buy products that are green my wife is
very strict about that and my kids
are really forcing us to make sure that
everything we do
is consistent with what we believe in
and i believe that's the core issue if
you're consistent with your beliefs
you feel better you feel better as a
citizen as a human being and we're
trying to do that
we fail sometimes sometimes we are a bit
inconsistent
um but every step helps of course as we
were saying before every action counts
when it comes to fighting climate change
not always listening to all these people
all their stories the inspiring things
that they are doing i was thinking
what is it that motivated you to become
a climate fighter
well i think mainly because we see that
we have a huge problem
um you know we now we're fighting a
pandemic
and thank thanks that we have
a vaccine coming up now that will help
us um
overcome this but for the climate crisis
there is no vaccine
for the biodiversity crisis there is no
vaccine so we need to change our ways we
really need to start living differently
not less not worse even better but we
need to recreate a balance with our
natural environment
if we want to survive as humanity you
know we always say it's about saving the
planet but the planet can take care of
itself
it was there a long time before we came
along it's going to be there a long time
after we've gone
but the time we spend on this planet we
better create a
balance with that planet to make sure we
can survive and it's very urgent
if we want to control what's happening
with the temperature
we need to be climate neutral by 2050.
if we want to be climate neutral by 2050
we have to reduce our emissions
drastically in 10 years time if we want
that to happen we have to put the
legislation in place
now so when i hold my grandson who was
born this summer
i promise to him once you are grown up
there will be measures in place that
will create
a better living environment for you that
will prevent
the climate crisis from being out of
control
but to get there i need to act now now
that he's a baby i need to act
if he is if he's to reap the benefits of
this when he's
an adult now europe doing the policy
part
here is the executive vice president of
the european green deal putting together
the legislation the euro pack pact is
more about engaging people is that
why you launch it because you believe in
the importance of every citizen
being active in events in the fight
against climate change well you know the
beauty of the climate fact is that it it
appeals to uh people
not as consumers but as citizens you
know too long in the last decades
we as politicians have treated people as
consumers and then we are surprised that
people start behaving like consumers
no people need to be part of this not
just asking us to come with the
solutions
but they have to shape the solutions
themselves that's why the practice so
important people can contribute
can give us their best ideas can learn
from others
the exchange is what excites me most you
know the best practices i'm doing this
i'm doing that
and you know i learn every day from
listening to citizens who are engaged in
this
it's actually that something that you
can build on on that
indeed um now lieutenant was mentioning
the importance of the youth engagement
and we saw two years ago greta fember a
swedish teenager
that decided to make a school strike for
the climate and she triggered a global
movement now i know that you've been in
contact with her and with
other john leaders and i was wondering
how that has
influenced the european green deal there
would be no european green deal without
them
it's that simple we campaigned for it in
the european elections
but if we didn't have this backing if we
didn't have this
huge movement then it wouldn't be there
because we needed to convince quite a
lot of
political forces to join us in this it
was a minority thing
at first but thanks to the young
generations it's now become something
that
has been embraced by almost all of
society i mean young people should be
very proud
of what they have achieved it's only a
beginning i know but it's a hugely
important beginning
we're talking about young people and
it's part of society that is actually
convinced but how can the climate pact
help to convince those who still have
doubts about climate change
by showing that whatever you do
yourselves the small steps they all
contribute
to that you know a couple of years ago i
was worried about climate deniers is
that there is no climate problem or the
temperature rise is normal
they are disappearing very quickly
because the evidence is becoming
overwhelming even for people who are
very skeptical
today i worry more about climate despair
people saying it's lost already we can't
do it what can i do as a person you know
this problem is too big
and the climate pact will show that it's
not lost
we can still save the day and everyone's
contribution matters even the smaller
steps
lead us to the path that will lead us to
a carbon neutral and climate neutral
society
in 2050. so you also think that this
path can actually convince those who are
already losing faith in the possibility
to actually
fight climate change well it will
empower people
to show that they can do something
themselves it's an empowering tool
it's not a tool it's not it's not a tool
to sort of go to people and say you
should be doing this
it's telling people look you have this
in your power to do this
and if you come together with others who
also share our view that we need to have
a climate mutual society
in 30 years 30 years is a blink of an
eye if we need
if we need to get there everyone should
contribute and the climate pact brings
people together
to learn from each other and also to
show what can be done
bringing people people together in a
situation like the one we are living
right now when everyone has to stay at
home with the
human connection somehow is lost do you
think it's
harder or is it more important than ever
i
really crave the human touch to
to quote bruce springsteen this is for
me something i miss most uh you know
i've
the last time i i held my grandson was
in september
uh and and i'm just giving my example
because i know so many millions out
there are in the same situation
and i think we as humanity are suffering
because we we can't
embrace literally embrace uh other
people so
second best is to try and work on the
future of humanity and
we can do this online through the
climate pact uh but there's
i mean there's no alternative uh to
meeting each other and embracing each
other again
but as long as we can't do that let's
start preparing for a better future
and the climate pack can help that and
online we can help do that
we have to make sure that we start
working now because otherwise we're not
going to make it as you said before
now i'm going to move into the program
uh
to explain to our citizens how they can
actually be part of the european climate
pact
the european climate part is all about
citizen participation that we were
saying
engagement activism in the fight against
climate change
now if you want to inform inspire and
support climate action in your community
you can become a volunteer climate pact
ambassador
now you might be thinking i have no idea
where to start
we're actually here to help you since
the opening of the call for the
ambassadors on december 9th there has
been
a great interest in becoming ambassadors
and the european commission is
very grateful for it here are five
people who are already active and want
to be part of the climate pact to
inspire you
president vanderlian and executive vice
president timmerman could not have put
it any better
making europe the first climate neutral
continent is the greatest challenge
and opportunity of our lifetime as the
vice mayor for environment and climate
in the city of stockholm
i know that cities have a vital role to
play in this transition
after all cities consume over 80 percent
of europe's energy
and account for more than 70 percent of
europe's co2 emissions
and everyone has the work to do now
in stockholm we are on our way to
becoming fossil fuel free and climate
positive by 2040.
the climatepackthis.com already gathers
300 companies
who wants to be part of this transition
as an ambassador for the european
climate pact i will not sit still until
i have spread stockholm's knowledge
experience and enthusiasm for ambitious
climate action to cities all over europe
we have a chance to make the european
green deal a real turning point
for our people and our planet and i
cannot
wait to make it happen with you
i'm francesca dandelo and i live in
paris as a former counselor of the city
center district
i've always been engaged in nature
protection
i developed awareness for biodiversity
with neighborhood residents by
initiating the project of a green
corridor to restore
local bird population insects and small
mammals in the city
the objective was to present the project
and convince the local council
developing and linking green corridors
all over the area
can be replicated all over the city and
internationally
on a local level over the past 10 years
i have organized two community gardens
where more than 200 residents have
participated
the city of paris offers digital tools
to amplify local initiatives
being a european union climate pact
ambassador
will enable me to inform and rally
grassroots organizations
local and regional councils around the
biodiversity initiatives the eu can help
with
did you know that heating and cooling
account for half of the eu's energy
consumption
and is still mostly for social based did
you know that 34 million europeans can't
keep their home
properly i'm marine caneles and i'd like
to be one of the first european climate
packed ambassadors
i was born in france but now i live with
my family in turin in northern italy a
beautiful city staring over the alps
the turin has also strong industrial
best and the air quality is one of the
worst in europe
my goal is to make sure that everyone
unites to reverse the trend
starting with energy and buildings i
want to give people simple
easy to understand tools so that i can
make the best choices
the most sustainable options will not
only be good for them and their family
but also soft for their wallet and
better for the planet
i will build on a professional
experience as an energy consumer right
expert and my personal experience as a
young mother
together we can get people out of energy
party and make sure that our children
live on a healed planet dear european
friends
my name is franz jelser and i'm active
for climate since four years
it started with my young board
membership at the royal dutch chemical
association
i hosted field trips and also public
discussions on chemical topics
from that i got engaged into the dutch
climbing agreement
and with young professionals from
various sectors we created cac
a foundation of young professionals for
sustainability
with cac i helped giving advice as a
team member for the industry table
and afterwards i became a board member
to do the community management
from the dutch climate agreement i
actually got more engaged afterwards
locally
and also on european level for instance
i helped setting up the basis for youth
participation
in the regional energy strategies and on
european level
i co-founded the green live for youth
network
it's a grassroots network that hosted
brainstorm sessions
on the european climate pact we
contributed to youth summits
in the netherlands sweden and cyprus on
the european green deal and we are now
getting engaged in the just transition
regions
with my ambassadorship i would like to
give these activities a boost with my
communities
and i think with the european climate
pact we can really make sure that all
stakeholders get involved
thank you hi my name is martin azad
and i'm a 26 year old rower from norway
i'm qualified for the tokyo olympics but
as you know back in march i had to go
back home to my hometown of
olson there i spent a lot of time in the
water
my favorite hobby is free diving and i
could see a lot of trash that's not
belonging there
so i thought that maybe i should start
this crowdfunding campaign which i've
been thinking over
for a while and so i said that for every
euro i get
in i'll pick one kilo of trash take a
picture of the trash
and show it to the people that gave me
the money
so this yeah the the wheel kept them
turning so now i've
picked over six tons of trash
and i'm aiming to pick more but this
problem is way bigger than me
so i brought this underwater
photographer named vasco pinot
with me and he was he's been documenting
the stuff that i find to try to make
some waves
try to make some change and see that the
problem is worldwide
well that was impressive if you see what
just one person can do imagine what we
can do together
and today we don't only have five but we
have 180 of our ambassadors joining us
from zoom
hello everyone how are you doing
and they're going to have a discussion
before we go into the questions from
slido and i want you to remember that
you can still ask your question or vote
for your favorite one because we're
going to choose
the most better ones to ask him by
executive vice president franz
timmermans
but before we're gonna have a
conversation with our ambassadors who
will be
joining us live on the studio
we have a lot of questions coming up
from always up for nowhere ambassadors
i'm happy to see that
they are willing to engage in this
conversation with executive vice
president
um can we give the floor maybe to
sebastian first
who is joining us today
i think we're not ready yet yes
good morning sebastian here from
northern germany hi
good morning mr executive president
timmermans and thank you a lot for the
support initiative and your personal
involvement in the climate issue
my question there are many fronts i
think we need to move faster on for
example individual action which is our
focus today
organizational or corporate action which
is for example driven by the
science-based
targets initiative or regulatory action
by governmental bodies which area do you
think should be focused on most to
generate maximum impact
thank you ah that's a
fascinating question but i believe we
cannot
we don't have the luxury to to choose
we have to have these actions on all
fronts all at the same time
and the beauty of it is that they
reinforce each other so if we would
or to concentrate only on uh one sector
the other sectors would
perhaps not feel empowered to do the
same but if we concentrate on all these
things at the same time
everybody doing their part you know the
european commission is about
making regulations uh making sure we
have the right
legal framework that's what we do but at
the same time we bring together
all sorts of people from all walks of
life and we can help
and support them in what they're doing
so i wouldn't prioritize but just
look at your own strength and operate on
the base of that strength and
i'm with the commission our strength is
to prepare good
legislation and good regulation that's
what we will concentrate on
but at the same time we can also be a
platform to bring all sorts of people
together
so that they can share their experiences
that's how i see also the climate pact
and we will be talking more about the
role of institutions organizations and
businesses later today in the program
because that's part of the european
climate pact as well
i would like to know it friends which is
already ready to join us on the studio
are you there friends
hello friends two friends yes
i can hear you good morning from munich
my name is van fuchs and i'm engaged at
the organizations of
parents for future in munich and my
question is
how we can get out from these subsidies
we do already in fossil
products and fossil industries because
we need those money very urgently
to to to drive the transition
and how we can get out of the subsidies
very quick that's my question
it's been a really yeah yeah this is
france with a zed at the end and i'm
france with an s so uh
but um it's an extremely good question
that's why yesterday we presented
uh the proposal from the commission to
redirect the subsidies we do in
the energy sector towards sustainable
energy and no longer
give support to fossil fuel
at the same time you also have to
stimulate the big energy companies to do
the same
and what i find fascinating is that even
big oil companies
a couple of years ago were still trying
to help climate
deniers and others to make their case
they have completely changed and they
are
reorienting their investment towards
sustainable energy
we need to stimulate that and how can we
do that
well we do with regulation as i said but
also we can
convince the the shareholders of these
companies
to push the companies even further in a
sustainable
direction so that they commit to being
climate neutral
in a certain period of time and that
their then they will redirect their
investment and disinvest
from fossil fuels i think we need to
stimulate that as much as we can and
sometimes
you know governments also take those
decisions the decision of the
danish government to no longer uh
exploit uh oil at some point
in and gas in the north sea is is one of
these uh
one of these decisions um but everything
we can do to push it in the right
direction is
is is helpful and the question of green
bones have been very important as well
for the european commission we've seen
that as well
um we're going to move now to matthew
back are you there matthew would like to
join us
hello matthew can you hear us
yes good morning can you hear me yes
great well i'm absolutely thrilled to be
here
on behalf of ukulele europe and and
thank you very much to mr timmermansfor
for all the answers
my question is cities have and towns and
regions have critical roles to play
in the implementation of the european
green deal and
we at ikley are working towards local
green deals which we think are the way
forward
our question here is how can the
european commission
support these local green deals as kind
of the rooted
bottom-up kind of starting point for a
successful and ambitious european green
deal
thank you very much we know at the
commission that you know if it has to
happen it has to happen locally
um and we are bringing together in the
covenant of mayors we're bringing
together and also
in the committee of the regions uh some
of
our ambassadors now are mayors or are in
local government
their voices are so important because
they can get things going
what i would like to add to that you
know the cities really want
because the people are are asking for
cleaner air they're asking for more bike
lanes they're asking for
uh emission-free public transport etc
etc
work we can work on that but what i
would also like to stimulate
is that we create strong alliances
between
cities and rural areas because one of my
biggest fears is that we
create a chasm between cities and rural
areas
and that they are on on a different
planet
almost literally in terms of the urgency
we need
cities cannot survive without
vibrant healthy rural areas and rural
areas
absolutely need the input of cities
to bring the new technologies to get
everybody on 5g
which is for the climate very important
and to bring agriculture into a
far more sustainable field so i would
say
i would say let's try and create
alliances between
urban areas and rural areas that is the
future also within the climate pact
absolutely key and also often is the
rural areas that face the most
consequences of the climate change so we
absolutely need to work together to make
sure that we prevent that from happening
now i think we have francesca who would
like to ask a question as well
are you there francesca yes i'm here
hello francesca
hello hello to everyone and uh hello to
mr
timmermans i'd like to ask a question
as an ambassador in dealing with
not-for-profit organizations and
institutions who need
financial support how can an ambassador
help to obtain eu funding
ah at some point there's always a
question about eu funding
but it's a good question it's a good
question because we want to try and
bring together
people whether they are funded or not
funded and those who are not funded
we're trying to help them
get the funds they need so i hope we can
also use the climate pact to do that
so bring it to the table bring it to our
attention and we
will see what we can do i can't make any
promises off hand
obviously but we will see what we can do
to support initiatives
that take us into into climate
neutrality
of course there is many ways in which
you can access your funds even by being
a citizen and being part of an
organization
now i'd like to give the floor to rafael
rafael are you there joining us today
good morning hello raphael can you hear
me
if you're asking me yes i'm right here
hello
the major warsaw with us today thank you
so much for being here today with us
yes it's wonderful to be with you um i'm
the mayor of warsaw
the capital city of poland and i'm very
happy to be with you
uh you know sometimes we fall into a
pessimistic mood but
um the messages from the european
council were fantastic
one very difficult government was
threatening a veto
and was threatening to each of the
budget and also you know our very
ambitious plans
when it comes to fighting climate change
decided
uh to uh actually agree uh on those
proposals
after some pushing and shoving and now
we can actually focus on those
priorities and the important thing is
that we have to do it with the cities
just as uh the
vice president francis timmermans was
explaining
we need to help the the underdeveloped
regions there's no doubt about that we
need to help
all the people in the mining regions all
the people have who have to re-qualify
who are the regions who have problems
when they have to move
uh from the coal economy but the
important thing is that we need to
engage
the cities because we are the ones
producing 70
of all the emissions and we are ready to
do it i mean most of the mayors that i
talked to and
you know i'm representing the committee
of the regions but i also am
within the uh uh pact of um
of uh mayor's convent of mayors
and now thanks to the european
commission i become the ambassador of
the green pact
i've talked to quite a lot of mayors and
we are very much committed to actually
meet those ambitious goals
and we are doing quite a lot ourselves
in warsaw itself we decided to
phase out you know all the coal powered
furnaces
we're changing our fleet of buses uh
into uh
zero emission buses we're building
subway system we're investing in
greenery
and we're ready to be ambitious why
first of all because we believe in it
but
secondly because we're close to the
citizens and when i walk the streets of
my city
all the time the young people are asking
me what are you doing mayor
to actually meet those challenges and of
course you know with such a pressure
we need to do it much more quickly and
we need to also
raise awareness we don't have to raise
the awareness among the millennials
but when it comes to our generation we
got to talk to people and tell them
you got to do yourself quite a lot in
order to contribute in order to save the
planet
in order to invest in quality of life
we're ready to do it and we are also
ready to talk about it
uh we're ready to uh use our own minds
and
uh our own uh own funds within our
cities
but we're also ready to cooperate to do
the benchmarking to actually use the
best examples in the cities in europe
and come up with plans with the european
institutions
which are going to actually demonstrate
to the people then we can change our
cities within just a few years we just
need the pan-european programs
we need the willingness of the european
commission but knowing france timmermans
pretty well and having talked to them on
numerous occasions
i know that we are going to do it
together
are we going to believe together
absolutely absolutely and and
now that rafa was on on the online i
would also like to say
who's affected most by the pandemic
the weakest and the poorest in our
society who's going to be affected most
if we can't get the climate crisis under
control the weakest
and the poorest in our society so we
need to make sure that what we do
is also socially sustainable and
and this is one of my biggest fears in
all of this that we would leave people
behind
we cannot afford to leave people behind
we need to protect
vulnerable people we need to make sure
that this is a
just transition into a sustainable
society
into climate neutrality and you know i
know rafa
pretty well he has that same challenge
in warsaw
um we will not get to where we need to
be
if not everyone in society feels part of
this
and if we start leaving people behind
they will stop this change from
happening
apart from the moral issue you cannot
leave people behind it's also then a
political issue
because you can't get done what you need
to get done so let's add the social
dimension to this because without it
we're never going to succeed absolutely
it's not only about convincing people
it's indeed about protecting people so
that they are part
of the change as well and they enjoy the
change um
we will be going again thank you rafael
for joining us today um
we will be going now to floriana are you
there
what would you like to ask secretary
vice president yes hello good
good morning everybody i i just would
like to understand
what he thinks about view the covet
tragedy the covey cries and what's
happened how you think
this is going to change the future
policy at your level
how everything happened or is still
happening to us
for the covey crisis is going really to
change something
um as you policy thank you
well i it perhaps is a bit early days
but in my
understanding the way i see things the
way i feel things
we're never going to go back to the
world as it was before never
not that we're going to be in a
permanent pandemic that's not what i'm
saying
but if we draw the right lessons from
this pandemic
we understand we need to change and if
we draw the other lesson from this
pandemic
that europe it took a while but europe
now understands that we can only come
out of this together
that's also going to change our policies
and i think people are very much aware
our citizens are very much aware
how vulnerable and fragile our
relationship is with our natural
environment
and how vulnerable and fragile we are as
human beings and as
individuals and how much we depend on
our society
and of being in this together on showing
solidarity
so i truly believe this is a moment it
could end up in two ways
either in a dystopian future where it's
everybody for themselves
and society ending up in permanent
conflict
or in a more solidarity-based society
where we understand
that we need to do this together and i
hope the climate pact can contribute
to building this society based on
well-understood self-interest
because that's how i would like to
define solidarity
and we've been seeing that uh until up
until now and i think it's a good news
that most of the things that we've been
seeing happening
uh during the pandemic has been this
solidarity building
across borders and and particularly in
europe we've seen uh quite a lot of that
and the european climate is going to be
key uh when it comes to
making the european green deal happen
i'd like to go now to terencio transfer
are you there hello how are you doing
yes i'm here hi thank you very much
uh the question that i was posing it is
uh concerning uh
um the agriculture uh
here where i'm living in amsterdam in
germany uh we have a
wonderful place called the offcut where
they have
all very extra value everything
they're still caressing all the
animals that they have and so on every
day in order to
make them very happy but if you're going
to buy things they
are extremely expensive and generally uh
all this
green food and so on is generally
more expensive than the other one that
you find out and i think that the target
should be to
to reverse the situation that but it is
greener should not be
more expensive but become a normality
and
less expensive than the other one i
understand that
behind the the green food there are
a lot of regulatory issues and things
that
make the price going up a certification
assessment and things like that
how could we handle or
could we do in order to reverse the
situation
other ways there will be always the rich
people they buy the green
and the poor people by the the rest
yeah this goes back to the same issue i
was mentioning before we can
not afford to leave people behind and
green
as he calls it green food should be
accessible to everyone for that
we need to help farmers transit to this
new
uh a way of producing uh to do that we
need to
support them now the problem the core
and we we've we're negotiating this now
with parliament and and council
uh to get so-called echo schemes which
would help farmers move to
ecological farming but the core of the
problem is this
many many farmers are extremely worried
to lose income in this transition
and the the issue with the common
agricultural policy is
sadly eighty percent of the money goes
to
twenty percent of the farmers so there
is a huge problem that the money is not
in my view reaching always the right
people the people working on the land
the the families with their farms the
families working on the land
they should be supported in this now too
much money is going to the big land
owners
and the big agro-industrial
complex corporations so we need to
reorient the common agricultural policy
in this direction i was mentioning so
that money reaches the people are
actually doing the work
more to do that we're negotiating it's
not easy at all
because of this fear of loss of income
but i think we can start redirecting the
policy
if we are successful in these
negotiations we definitely have a very
hard fight ahead
yes absolutely um i'd like to go
to irina now that is joining us today
hello irina are you there
hi irina are you there hello hello hi
what would you like to ask oh i have so
many questions
um maybe i start
with the most money thing so is there
any chance
that the eu commission is withdrawing
the cap
because only 30 of all all this money is
going to green
funding and 70 is going to
old fossil
prone things but
okay i guess this is a rather big
question
just yesterday we had
uh and a petition to the german
bundestag
uh that we would like to have a citizen
council on climate
as they have in france and ireland and
successfully
so do you think that the eu commission
could nudge
the uh all the governments and
especially the german
to have those councils because because
of the petition they need to
consider it but they don't need to
make it happen so could you help with
that well my advice to
to national governments would be to look
at what's happened in france
to look at the impact of this dialogue
with citizens
because that's how the french government
learned that there is a
huge support in the population for
climate policy
and now the french government are even
considering putting this
in the constitution through a referendum
um
and and i would hope other other
countries would follow this example of
course
cultures differ so it's not going to be
the same
format everywhere but this idea of
having people discuss this and then
drawing the consequences from this
discussion in your policy choices
is creating empowered citizenship
and that's what we're trying to do with
the climate pact as well
and on the on the first question because
i'm not dodging your question on the
common agriculture it was inevitable
at all the commission can always
withdraw
if we believe that um the
the end result is far removed from
the content of our proposal but if we
withdraw we then have to have
a proposal that could get the majority
support that is better
and today in good conscience i cannot
say that i could put a proposal on the
table
that would get the majority in the
council or in in parliament that is
better
so what i'm doing i'm putting all my
skills and
and and efforts in fighting in these
negotiations
so instead of saying let's withdraw i'm
saying
let's try and improve it as much as we
can and then we will draw the conclusion
at the end of the negotiation
um and i know that you know common
agriculture policy used to be quite an
esoteric business
only farmers and the ones who
represented them were engaged in this
but irena has shown clearly that now why
the society is looking at this
this is no longer a very small issue it
concerns
everyone in society and i would urge
irina and all the others
who feel passionate about this to let
their voices be heard also to their
national
politicians because the leaders of our
nations
they are very much committed to climate
neutrality
but they will should also have a site on
the agriculture policy because if we
can't get the agricultural policy to be
reformed
we can never get to climate neutrality
in 2015.
the importance of talking to the
national government as well and national
politicians that we sometimes forget
it's not only
happening everything in brussels we're
going to go to
kai now hello kai how are you doing
what would you like to answer hello i'm
fine and i want to say
thank you for selection of the naga
foundation as a volunteer ambassador
we working on international dialogue and
transfer of knowledge and
technology it's already mentioned
technology is
one of the keys and we you know that we
have different
levels already in europe from country to
country
from city to city but we also have a big
part in the world of developing
countries if we look to our neighborhood
continent africa the growing of
population
the coal oil for cellular sources there
so how the european commission wants
to support international dialogue and
transfer of
technology and solutions and also the
work of the ambassadors
what we're doing there thank you well i
would like
our ambassadors to help me convince
everyone
that africa is our sister continent
and that thing if things go badly in
africa they will go badly in europe
and if things go badly in europe they
will go badly in africa so our fates
are linked interlinked that's the first
point my second point in this
is this sub-sahara africa
produces less energy from solar power
than the netherlands um so there is a
huge potential
uh in africa for um
power generation on the base of
renewable energy wind and solar
so if we help investment in those
countries
to go into that direction they can
leapfrog over a number of developments
we made before
and they can avoid a number of mistakes
we have made
now initially african countries were
quite reluctant because they believed
that we would put
more more burden on them and not help
them but what i have seen in the last
year two years is that in african
countries there is
a huge realization of the effects
of climate change already now on them
um the fact that south africa has now
committed
south africa huge coal producer to get
out of coal and to
work towards climate neutrality is
incredible
but it comes after the realization
that these nations that this continent
is highly affected already by climate
change
look at the the locust plagues we've
seen in in eastern africa
look at the unpredictable weather now
the seasons that can no longer be
banked upon etc it's causing havoc
the strong point of africa we sometimes
in in the european public opinion we
look at africa and say oh my god all
these young people
they're going to come here i look at
africa and i say
wow look at these young people they can
build a very strong continent they can
they are smarter healthier than ever
before they get more education than ever
before
if we help empower them they can build a
powerhouse
which is our sister continent and then
we both profit
whether it's in solar energy and wind
energy and hydrogen economy
in all sorts of areas so i am optimistic
as soon as we understand that our
destinies are linked
i think it's very important when you
were saying about all the many
opportunities that is in africa
especially when it comes to sustainable
energy indeed and these passionate
leadership that we were talking about
before about just young people we're
going to go now to julius
hello julius how are you
hello i'm good can you hear me yes we
can
great um what i wanted to get at is the
international dimension sometimes as an
activist
uh i feel a bit powerless because uh as
youth organization
organizations we try to avoid single-use
plastic cups we try to avoid plastic
bags and so on and so forth we try to
take the bus
and not take cars but then the real big
polluters
um and now i don't mean that we in
europe we don't pollute a lot per capita
we pollute an immensive lot but in terms
of
um really big polluters outside of
europe
i'm really afraid that these might not
take the lead they should take
and i'm asking how can the european
union utilize
their levy which is perhaps access to
the single market
in order to force also the big polluters
i'm thinking about
a very big country in the east that
produces a lot of goods from europe
how can how can we make them also uh
conform to this to this uh climate
ambition and
um what are your thoughts on for example
an idea like
like a carbon import tax what are your
ideas on regulation regarding
ships because i understand that
container ships that cross the sea
uh lack an enormous amount of regulation
in terms of their emissions
how can we make the world sign up to
this climate pact because if only we
change in europe
yes it's going to make our conscience
better we're going to be the first
carbon
neutral continent in the world but is
that going to save
humanity or do we actually need to go
beyond that and also make the world
change
yeah absolutely you're absolutely right
we need to make the world change and
um a year ago when we said we'd take
european leadership we will go for
climate neutrality in 2015.
many were saying what are you talking
about it's gonna be expensive
we're only responsible for nine percent
of the emissions it will not really have
an impact
but if you look at where we are now xi
jinping
committing to being carbon neutral in
2016
and then following that up with concrete
steps um
a new administration coming in the
united states saying they will rejoin
the paris agreement and then have some
very very
far-reaching steps to go towards climate
neutrality
japan has declared climate neutrality
2050
korea has done the same south africa i
mentioned already before
this is starting to become a global
movement and i think
they're not doing it just because of
european leadership absolutely not
they're doing it out of
well understood self-interest if china
wants to
restructure its economy so to answer
more domestic demand rather than just
export
they need to make sure the carbon
footprint per capita is going down
otherwise they'll suffocate in their own
emissions so
there's always an element of
self-interest but also the fact that
europe has said
if you don't take those measures we will
have to protect our industry
by introducing carbon border adjustment
mechanism at the border as you mentioned
has also pushed them in saying what can
we do to avoid
being getting a levy before we can get
into the european market well
by taking the same steps as we are doing
so that there is a level playing field
and i believe these are the measures we
need to be taking
and we are preparing as european
commission proposals
to protect certain parts of our industry
if they take the right measures to
decarbonize
and they're faced with competition from
elsewhere where they don't take the
right measures then i think we are
enough for right
to protect our industry and then if you
want to come on the european market
you will have to comply with those rules
not just in terms of your calm footprint
but let's also mention
the issue of deforestation we don't want
to be responsible as citizens
for the deforestation of primal forests
in latin america
in central africa or in southeast asia
so we'll have to
introduce rules that products coming as
a result of deforestation no longer
have a role in the european market these
are the things we need to do
but i am more optimistic than i am a
year ago nobody's telling us you're
crazy you're taking a lead and nobody is
following
we see step by step the world joining us
in this and that gives me
a cause to be optimistic the proof of
the pudding will be in november next
year in glasgow
when we meet for the next cop then
everyone has to put
their plans on the table and show that
they are on a track
to comply with the paris agreement and
let me at the end remind you of one
thing
if we don't do this if we don't keep the
rise of the temperature
well below two degrees things will be
completely out of control
humanity will then no longer be able to
control
what is happening in our climate and
that is something
we need to avoid for our kid's sake in
my case even for my grandkids sake
um and we can we have to do it now this
cannot wait
that is the that is the most complicated
thing about climate policy
if we want to get where we need to be in
30 years time we have to act now today
tomorrow the next day and definitely as
julius was saying it's something that
europe alone cannot do
i think it's very important the question
of the soft power of the you not only
through diplomacy but also through
regulation
at also a global level we're going to
take our last question for our
ambassadors
from laura hello laura how are you doing
what would you like to ask hello i would
like to
ask what exactly mr timmerman would like
would recommend to do right after this
meeting at the eu
level as an ambassador for climate
at eu level what should we do is there a
master
um project plan in place should we build
one
otherwise so all together
we are taking action not
where we are today in our initiative
but at a master level
eu level well i think if you ask me what
what should we be doing immediately as
ambassadors
get to know each other create this
network make it strong the network
and then let's look at what we can do in
the short term
get the renovation wave going which we
have proposed as commission
which means work with cities and other
regions
to look at their plans for buildings how
we can renovate buildings
insulate them better put solar panels or
heat pumps in them
create the right infrastructure in
cities invest in that so that we get
jobs back
as soon as possible come with the best
ideas
share them you know say oh i heard from
the mayor in warsaw he's doing that hey
and i heard from the
vice mayor in stockholm she's doing that
how can we use that in my city
and then make sure you also address your
national politicians
as strongly as you can force them to
present plans to us
for the recovery phase that are in the
in
climate direction and make sure that
all the good ideas are shared so that we
can also
when we talk with national governments
point in that direction and tell them to
uh improve the plans they have and then
work also with the european parliament
get the corporate world into this
because
one of the big surprises to me was that
there is a
huge understanding in the corporate
world that they need to change very
quickly as well
uh stimulate them to change let them say
what they're doing perhaps they could
inspire you
as well and then if we do all that
make sure you take people along who will
not necessarily immediately
feel part of this especially small or
medium-sized
entrepreneurs who are thinking about how
am i going to survive next month you
know if
if if your worry is how am i going to
get to next month
uh you're not that worried about how
you're going to get to 20
20 50. so if you can help them with that
it would also create
another support for the movement a lot
of work for laura and for the other
ambassadors
part of the flag of course um and i
wanted to thank all the ambassadors
today for joining us and for this very
interesting conversation with executive
vice president and also tell you
that you can actually apply to become an
ambassador we will be sharing more
information about how you can do it
today at the end of the program thank
you so much everyone thank you for
joining us today
and now we're going to buy we're going
to go back to the questions that the
audience is asking
through slido and the first question is
from john simon whitman
and he's asking why are only 30 percent
of the corona aid
funds put towards crema friendly
solution don't we have to make
all in the upcoming investment green and
sustainable
if we want to remain true fully
regarding our desire to become
clementro well first of all we said that
all the money should do no harm
so that's already an improvement so
every euro invested
should not be invested in things that go
in the wrong direction so that
creates consistency and then we're
saying uh in the recovery
part 37 should be spent on climate
policy 20 percent of digitization
and then you come to 57 in total because
digitization is an
integral part it's the biggest and most
important enabler
of climate policy i i would say so they
stick together so i think the situation
is a bit
a bit more positive than you might think
um but all in all i think if we look at
the plans that have been submitted so
far by member states
they've understood that they need to
change and and need to change direction
as well
so i'm slightly more optimistic than
perhaps the questions
would suggest and let's keep pushing for
this and the more we push
the more projects we will get but
i also have to be honest in the sense
that we only have a small win of
opportunity
four years we need high quality uh
projects and we need to make sure the
money is not squandered
so we have to be very very precise when
we talk to member states about what
they're doing
so what i would hate to see happen is
so-called helicopter money just throwing
money out of the window
we need to make sure that the money is
put to good use there you can
you can check on us and you can follow
us and and we need to prove
to the climate pact to our citizens that
what we're doing is taking us in the
right direction
and there the role of the commission in
looking into the national plans is
absolutely vital
yes the second question is coming from
miroslav poser
he's asking what is the global dimension
of the european climate pact are there
any links to global campaigns and
programs of the united
nations system like the race to serial
campaign or the action climate
empowerment program
well what we're doing with the with the
climate pact
actually goes into the same direction as
what
secretary general guterres of the united
nations is advocating
as what we're doing with the
sustainability programs we have any
everywhere
the sustainable development goals
at the 17 at the uh global level so it's
all
in sync i would say and the more we can
link
into global initiatives of citizens the
better it is there are some in the
united states there are some at the
global level
and this is also something for the
climate pact ambassadors to discover and
to
help us find the right initiatives and
link into them
of course they can have their own
projects that go beyond the european
borders
most of the project will go beyond the
european borders i would say
indeed soon we have a third question
from pranav
uh he said 100 companies are responsible
for 71
of global emissions aggressive lobbying
tactics employed by
these companies to persuade the european
legislators is too damaging to society
can we
overload loving from these companies
well i think that
those companies depend a lot on
investors
for their future first of all what i
didn't mention yet which is important to
understand we're also in an industrial
revolution
so industry is changing anyway our task
is to make sure that it changes in the
right direction
and we need to show especially to
investors
that if they invest in the traditional
economy in fossil fuels etc
their investment will be lost they will
start to create
so-called stranded assets and how are
they going to explain that because these
investors work with money that come from
pension funds from citizens
so they need to be accountable to that
and i i have seen even
you know the biggest investors in the
world are really changing direction
because they understand they can no
longer continue what they're doing
and that is educating all these
companies as well that they need to
change
so i have seen in the last year they're
abandoning all these policies trying to
undermine
the green deal etc and they're jumping
on the bandwagon they're also saying
okay
if we want to have a future as major
corporations we need to be climate
neutral in the future
let's start investing in that direction
and we will have to devise legislation
that pushes them even more in that
direction that's what we'll be doing
i think that's key as well the minute
that you know that the legislation is
going to push you away from that market
you wouldn't invest on that because it
has no future
and what they're asking of us give us
legislation okay it can be tough
but make it predictable and make it
sustainable so that it lasts for a long
time
if it is predictable and we know what we
face in 10 years time we know exactly
what we can do to invest and
i think this is a good deal between
corporations and ourselves
we need to be consistent and predictable
and they need to change
because the businesses also need to know
what they have to do to be part of the
change another question from magnus
according to the eu emission gap report
from 2019 we need to reduce emissions by
7.6 each year to be in line with the
paris agreement
this means that 70 reduction compared to
1990
by 2030. why does the green deal not
take that into account
we've done what we call an impact
assessment which is study all the
elements uh
in in in how we can reduce
uh emissions we came to the conclusion
that if we reduce our emissions with 55
percent
as compared to 1990 by 2030 we're still
on track to get to climate utility in
2050. i stick to that
because what what one of the weaker
points in analyses that
say we need to do more is that they
discount the fact that other parts of
the world are also
starting to engage and i i think europe
should take
a huge share of responsibility also for
historic reasons
you know this is where the industrial
industrialization started
this is where the fossil economy started
we have a huge responsibility
more so than uh developing much more so
than developing countries but
there are other industrialized parts of
the world who also have a responsibility
and we cannot as europeans take all the
responsibility
simply because we only have nine percent
of the emissions so
if others start taking their share of
the responsibility and
all indications are they're starting to
do that then our minus 55 target is
is enough to get us to climate
neutrality in 2015. and the good news is
that we had an agreement on the european
council to achieve that goal
we will have also a very long fight on
the well
hopefully not so long on the climate law
that we have ahead with the commission
and uh with the council and with the
parliament as well that's where
the questions from our public i want to
thank you very much for being here today
with us
and for answering all the questions of
from all different citizens
across europe i'm sure that they are
very happy to have this conversation
with you and they will take all that
lessons from them when they go and they
do their work as uh klamath pax
ambassador thank you again for being
with us
thank you for doing a great job thank
you so much
well now let's move into the next part
of the program but first
let's have a look at how alex is doing
with her drawing
hello alex oh that's beautiful
thank you so much alex now as important
as raising awareness is to
take action and every action counts
another way you can join the climate
pact is by making a pledge now
this could go from committing to a small
changes at home to live a more
sustainable life
to bolder bigger initiatives that can
inspire others as well
if you are a regular citizen like me but
you would like to make a pledge to
reduce your carbon footprint
you might want to check us contacts in
which is an initiative that aims at
mobilizing one
billion people to act on climate change
but i will leave the incredible
christian figures who is the former un
climate chief
and nico rosberg formula one world
champion
and climate checked activists to tell
you more about it
hello friends i'm cristiana figueres a
very proud costa rican citizen
but here is my little secret i
actually come from european extraction
my grandparents on my paternal side
were spanish my grandparents on my
maternal side
were danish so way deep down in the
bottom of me there
is a very proud little european
corner and that is why i'm very happy to
be joined today
by nico rosberg who will
help us to go through an exciting
european initiative
hello to all of you thank you very much
cristiano i am a very proud eu citizen
and best known maybe for my past as an
f1 champion
but now a sustainability entrepreneur
and super excited to support you
christiana and the eu
on achieving this ambitious new target
so nico is a great example of the kinds
of
transformations that we want to see and
many of you
will have been informed of the fact that
just last weekend we celebrated the
fifth
anniversary of the adoption of the paris
agreement
and we celebrated the fact that
something that was unthinkable close to
science fiction just five years ago
which was the concept of net zero by
20 50 net zero emissions
from any sector from any person from any
city from any corporation from any
country
by by 2050 that was frankly unthinkable
five years ago and probably the most
most
difficult component to land and to adopt
into the paris agreement but it was done
with the work of thousands of people to
be able to get to that conclusion
since then since then what appeared
impossible five years ago has now become
unstoppable
now we see a growing number of countries
the last list of which came on saturday
adopting net zero commitments by 2050.
we see a growing list of corporations
coming forward with net zero commitments
by 2050
some of them actually accelerating it to
2040
and some even to 20 30
because what they are doing is they are
understanding that decarbonization is
actually good for innovation and for
efficiency and they are pulling the
future
into the present so that is governments
moving forward
corporations moving forward financial
sector moving forward with a growing
number of alliances
of all different parts of the financial
sector coming forward to commit to net
zero
by 2050 but there is one key
piece that also needs to be moved and
that is all of
us individuals citizens certainly of the
eu
but worldwide who also have the
responsibility
and the opportunity to contribute to
the new world that we are together
creating
and as an ambassador of exactly that of
your initiative christiana called count
us in
i'm really proud to announce the big
partnership between countersin
and the eu climate pact and this is
where we come in we
hope to really help to mobilize eu
citizens to help achieve this new
ambitious goal
of reducing emissions by 55 by
2030 for the eu continent which is very
very ambitious
and so count us in it really lays out a
plan
for all of us citizens in 16 steps and
primarily it covers
the areas of our buildings so so how we
live
our transport how we move the food we
eat
and finally also the products we buy
and so at this point i would love to ask
all of you
to check out countersin.org and let us
know
can we count you in
and the counting piece is really
important because this
is about every citizen contributing
the count as in aggregator that is
behind this website
will allow us to count in many different
ways it will aggregate
first the carbon savings of the steps
that are taking
the number of individuals taking steps
and the number of steps taken
and you can contribute to that
aggregator
you can put all of your efforts in there
and
watch the aggregator increase
exponentially
as we all contribute our efforts
thank you very much for listening and
remember let's all be stubborn optimists
as cristiano loves to say
[Music]
what seemed impossible five years ago is
now unstoppable i'm gonna keep that with
me
during uh today's show now thank you so
much nico and cristiana for
your initiative and for your work for
now only
you can make only the pledges in english
but we are working on it so you will be
able to do it in your own language
very soon now beyond individual action
the role of business citizen
organization is vital
in building a more climate friendly
society
here you have some examples of how
pledges from various organizations could
look like
[Music]
uefa is today committing to the european
green deal
not only as an organization but as a
guardian of football
the most popular sport worldwide
[Music]
saving our planet is a pressing
emergency for all of us
with our european climate pledge uefa is
committing to
setting science-based targets to reduce
uefa's emissions
in line with the paris agreement goals
[Music]
creating a three-year joint tv ad
campaign
to broadcast the european green deal
into hearts and homes across europe
[Music]
establishing a green deal working group
including national football associations
and other football stakeholders in the
lead-up
to euro 2024 and alongside uefa
as co-organizers of this european
championship will aim to make this
tournament
the most sustainable and
climate-friendly euro in history
european football stands with the
european union in leading the charge of
climate action across the continent
hello i'm sam lee i'm a musician
conservationist
and environmental campaigner and i'm
faye milton i'm also a musician and both
sam and i
are founder members of music declares
emergency
congratulations on the launch of climate
pact and thank you for inviting us to
take part
music declares emergency as a group of
artists music industry professionals and
organizations who have declared an
environmental emergency
our declaration is calling on
governments to act urgently
on climate and biodiversity loss and to
reach net zero greenhouse gas emissions
by no later than 2030
we recognize that the emergency has
arisen from global injustices
and so we're committing to working
towards systemic change
to protect all life on earth music
declares emergency acknowledges the
environmental impact of
our industry's practices and commits to
taking urgent action
through our no music on a dead planet
campaign we pledge that over the next
year we will harness the incredible
power of the music industry
to engage the public with a positive
vision of how we can overcome the
climate and ecological emergency
in the run-up to cop 26 in glasgow our
industry has an incredible opportunity
to strengthen and galvanize public
support to the eu
green deal music and culture have a
unique ability to reach communities all
over the world
and cultivate positive vision for the
future keep up the good work because
remember
there's no music on a dead planet thanks
for listening
hi my name is martha and i was born in
the canary islands in spain
i'm a youth representative for the
european scout region
there are over 2 million scouts in
europe scouts are agents of change in
their own communities
scouts take action and inspire others to
work for a greener europe
for example scouts in croatia are
running a large-scale project of a
forest station
called maranga with the scouts of spain
we are working to save the bees
we have disseminated plant seeds in
order to grow
more flowers i myself since i was little
participated annually
in refrigeration and cleaning beaches
campaign i am currently part of the
scans of spain sustainability team
when we work to unlock the power of
young people through education
dumb people learn about sustainable
lifestyles to change their own behaviors
and how to mobilize their peers
in order to fight against climate change
and to protect environment
we scouts want to make a pledge today
engage even more in our local
communities
we will promote talk and educate about
climate change
through non-formal education activities
we will also advocate
a local regional and national level for
ambitious climate action
technology companies have a critical
role to play in europe's ambitious
green deal goals and google's been
carbon neutral since 2007
we're aiming to operate on carbon free
energy everywhere at all times
by 2030 so we're proud to play our part
and in this spirit we're delighted to
join the eu climate pact to help achieve
the green deal vision
let me tell you a little bit more about
our specific commitments
first sharing ai advances that we've
made that can help others
we're partnering with european
industries to become more energy
efficient with ai
offering them the same technology that's
helped us to cut
the energy costs for cooling our data
centers by 30
so that commercial buildings airports
shopping malls and other data centers
can also reduce their own carbon impact
second our 10 million euro impact
challenge on climate change will fund
bold ideas
that can accelerate europe's greener
future
third investment and jobs two billion
euros of investment for new carbon
energy
carbon free energy generating projects
and for green infrastructure in europe
and over 2000 new clean energy jobs in
europe by
2025. fourth
we'll work with cities across europe to
help them reduce their carbon emissions
by
one gigaton per year by 2030.
fifth for everyone through all of our
core products we'll continue to
prioritize the most authoritative
sources
and voices on topics prone to
misinformation including climate change
this encompasses servicing information
panels on youtube to provide users with
context
alongside their content sixth
and finally we're also supporting
europeans who want to learn new skills
so that everyone
has the chance to succeed as we create a
greener and more digital future
this is going to be a decisive decade
not just for europe
but for the whole planet i'm delighted
google can be a part of the new eu
climate pact
and look forward to working together for
a carbon-free
future
hello everyone my name is robert golob
i'm the ceo of company gen i from
slovenia
we are the largest electricity supplier
in our home country
my ultimate goal is to leave the world
more sustainable
than i found it we lead by example
we were the first company in slovenia to
offer affordable solar power plants for
self-consumption to our citizens
we have electrified 70 of our car fleet
but we're aiming for 100
we also have our own micro emobility
application for our employees
we follow climate-friendly trends in
corporate culture too
we have a corporate garden where our
employees are going fruits
vegetables and herbs and not to mention
we also raise honey bees
we will set new standards with energy
plus corporate headquarters
and as of january 2021
we will provide our customers
exclusively electricity from carbon
neutral and renewable energy sources
we have decided to embark on a fossil
fuel-free
future we certainly hope others will
follow
music football scouting and of course
businesses there is a place for everyone
and for
everything in the european climate pact
now we're learning today about all the
incredible things that people are doing
across europe to protect the environment
this morning i ask you what have you
done today for clement
after all these stories that you have
heard in this almost two-hour show
now i want you to tell me what would be
your pledge
now after all that you have heard let us
know through a slider and i will get
back to your answers a little bit later
but now in the meantime let me introduce
you to pekka
natasha marie stefan and emmanuel who
will be sharing
their pledges today with us hello becca
how are you doing i think you're joining
us from finland right
yes good morning everyone happy to join
you this morning and
it's snowing outside which is great and
and so saving our winters is important
in the future
tell me a little bit more about yourself
and what it is your pledge
and why did you decide it to do in the
european climate pact
i'm a mayor of a city called lahti which
is in southern finland 100 kilometers
northeast from our capital helsinki and
this is a city region of 200 000 people
most of the europeans live in the cities
and communities of our size so this is a
very typical european
city here we are the european korean
capital next year 2021
chosen by the european commission so we
have a very long
long story in environmental programs and
and doing climate action too
my pledge is very simple as the mayor of
the europe next year's european green
capital i
i and our city will do the all what we
can
is in our hands and do to to link the
cities together
to make sure that all cities learn from
each other
share knowledge and inspire each other
in order to move faster
and in some cities to start actions now
so linking to cities together inspiring
each other
and making sure the cities that are
crucial actually
in in in order to meet the targets of
the climate pact and and
green deal are active and do what they
are in their hands to do
we can and we can we we can actually do
a lot because
my city is a good example of that we are
a typical city also because
um we are an old industrial city doing
now the transformation in the more
sustainable green economy and leaving
the old past behind
we are not the biggest we are not the
richest we are not the most resourceful
city
in europe and yet we have done a lot so
my kind of message is always if we can
do this every one
every city and everyone can do this um
already today we are
we are we have cut our emissions by 70
and lofty will be carbon neutral by 2025
which is tomorrow
and this is not the political statement
this is the path we are now following
already cut i've cut our emissions by 70
percent
we don't have a landfill anymore here in
latin we
we have a very highly developed circular
economy 99
of our municipal waste is recycled or
utilized otherwise
and and and then we are now opening a
carbon neutral construction
learning and knowledge center to make
sure that all infrastructure
what we are building will be uh
carbon neutral and and very sustainable
in the future
and next next summer we are electrifying
our traffic so you can do a lot
and my my kind of wish is also that the
european
um climate pact and the green deal will
help cities in europe
to move faster to start action and
really support this transformation what
all cities
must do and then finally citizen
participation we can't do this with our
dear citizens and it's not if a mayor
says something
people might believe it or not but so
that's why here in lotte we have a long
long time involved our citizens from
children
to elderly people to be part of this
transformation and
we have even used our ice hockey team
which is the biggest spot here in
finland
to be our ambassadors and they will be
the world's first professional carbon
neutral sports team
they can talk to people they can send
the message so
you can do a lot and finally as a mayor
sustainable city will and must be a
better city
it's not enough to say that yes we meet
these targets and numbers
it must be a better city more inspiring
a better place to live
and that's what motivates me and our
citizens here in lotte
and i i was thinking that now that you
were mentioning these team members of
the hockey team they should become
ambassadors for the european club
environment you think i was wondering
i can ask them i can ask them absolutely
i was wondering how do you think the
climate pact is going to help you to
achieve these these exchanging practices
with other cities
engaging with them and making sure that
they too
join the european green deal first of
all it's very important that european
sends a very clear and strong message
this is what we do together here in
europe so that's the
even the framework is very important
then also it's very important that we
have these
kind of tools and different ways to do
this
and also of course in the big picture
also it's very important that's already
discussed that
the eu funding is really targeted on the
on the impact and and things that really
can make a change an impact
but i think this is a great opportunity
for all cities in europe we
we must be active and also cities can be
i hope
also the european union has a dialogue
with the cities all over the europe to
figure it out what would be the best
ways of moving forward but yes
this is a big thing it's important for
us and i think it provides us a lot of
possibilities to move further
looking forward to see all the beautiful
things that you're going to do in your
city becca thank you so much for sharing
your experience with us here today
thank you now i would like to introduce
natasha hi natasha how are you doing
hello good morning everybody
i'm fine thank you so natasha tell us a
little bit about yourself what did you
do
and what is your pledge and why do you
think the european climate part can help
you to achieve that pledge
okay uh so uh i am from
suburb it's someone beautiful city
museum
city um from period of secession
uh it is a city on north on serbia i
worked as a preschool teacher
more than 20 years in a classroom with
children from
three to seven years old and
also i am etwinning ambassador of serbia
i am ambassador of sustainable the
development
goals and
my opinion is that education has one of
the lead roles in educating
and reducing climate change and
learning about sustainable development
both
also my preschool institution
participated in some global projects
uh global goals project and climate
action project
and we involved or
maybe implemented the sustainable
development goals in our
yearly plans
i think that we can do a lot of a lot of
things that individuals
uh to work on small everyday change
in our behavior and develop
responsibility
for the future of our planet and also i
think that is
much harder to teach adult people to
change behavior
than teach children from the early years
to be responsible citizens
so my opinion is that children can be
agents
of change and also i noticed that
people are not informed
enough about climate change change
and sustainable development goals also
teachers are not important informed
enough
so one of the most important thing is
to educate the teachers how to
teach children about
climate change and sustainable
development goals
so what you would like to do is teach
teachers
so that they are ready and they have all
the information
yes one of the main tasks for me will be
to organize uh
various webinars and trainings to
teachers in cooperation with our local
community with
office for sustainable development from
our town and also i think that
we should connect with many various
institutions to connect with
other countries to connect with other
ambassadors
and to share our knowledge to share our
vote good practice
also i was i would like to say
that preschool institution
nasharados has five active
iraqus projects and three of them
are closely connected with the climate
change
yes go ahead and we will organize the
conferences mobilities we will exchange
good practice uh between uh various
european countries which are partners in
this
project so i was thinking i'd imagine
this toddler being taught about climate
change how did they
react when you told them about all the
different challenges that we have ahead
and do they go after and talk to their
parents and explain
that to them so that they can join the
fight against climate change
um yes it's very interesting uh they
think that
children don't have uh so so much
knowledge but
children are very creative and
they are active participants and
and they have so many ideas
how to to make change
they uh have many solutions to solving
problems
they are little innovators and uh
they can do a lot uh to
to spread their their ideas to their
parents
to other citizens especially if we
connect
with media for instance
and they all have this sensitivity
towards nature and animals that we
sometimes like when you grow up
as an adult as well right so it's very
important to engage them
since they are very little because as we
were talking about before this is a
long-term change
and we need actors uh to make that
change happen
indeed thank you so much natasha for
joining us today it was lovely talking
to you and thank you for everything that
you're doing you're actually training
the future generation that will protect
the environment thank you so much for
your work
now i would like to introduce thank you
so much and i would like to
introduce now marie estefan how are you
doing
good morning fine thank you good morning
i love the liturgy that you're bringing
to the show please let us know
what is it that you're doing and how is
the european climate patch
helping you thank you very much beatrice
it is a real pleasure
and an honor to be with you today and to
speak on behalf
of the philanthropy coalition for
climate my name is maurice stefan
mahadex and i am the executive director
of the bandina carrasco foundation
an independent family foundation
operating in france and spain
so very european so i have co-initiated
the philanthropic coalition for climate
hosted by daphne
the european umbrella organization of
more than ten
thousand philanthropic foundations this
coalition
is supporting foundations across europe
that fund
and engage with local initiatives on
climate action
usually in areas where public funding or
commercial investments are not happening
and i would like to give you three
examples of the works done
by foundations the german chef flynn
stiftu
is funding the non-profit journalism and
research office corrective
corrected as a climate editorial office
and is running a project on
climate-friendly mobility transport
in the western german region of the
rural rural area
second the guerrilla foundation is
supporting several local grassroots
movements
across europe among others protests
against
against deforestation of the ambassador
forest
at the german energy company lwe
the movement forces free culture in the
netherlands and
the very famous extinction rebellion in
the uk
and the third example is coming from my
foundation
the members of the network european
foundations on sustainable agriculture
and food
chaired by the caracao foundation and
hosted by the european foundation
center have aligned their strategy and
funding
in order to have civil society in
several european countries
such as france italy spain and poland
and germany
to advocate for a greener common
agricultural policy
and more specifically for its real
implementation
in national action plans this dialogue
with national policy makers was strongly
mentioned by
vp timmermans not long ago and i really
insist
that cap has to be reformed if you want
to reach our targets for a
climate neutral europe and indeed we
have to help
our farmers in this process so the
support of foundations
is crucial for these projects and
initiatives as they would not exist
without this philanthropic funding
foundations
are flexible responsible they integrate
the right
the risk dimension in their dna and they
are close to the field
to identify needs and innovative
solutions
the corona crisis has daily proved the
importance of foundations
to support civil society working closely
with the most vulnerable
above all foundations are keen on
collaborations
between foundations among themselves but
also with public bodies
at all geographical levels and with
other private partners
we don't bring the big money compared to
public one but we have a long proven
that we have a strong leverage effect
still i am convinced that so much more
could be done and should be done from
the philanthropy in europe
philanthropy that annually spent 60
billion euros
for public goods this is why the pledge
of the philanthropic coalition for
climate
of the european climate pact is to
commit
that we will promote the philanthropic
commitment on climate change
across europe and beyond over the last
12 months
130 foundations the uk
france and spain have signed up to this
commitment
that ask for implementing a climate
length to our programs
programs we fund to our investments that
we have with our endowments
and to our operations i am looking
forward for europe's philanthropy sector
to
join forces with the european commission
and all the stakeholders
of the european climate pact to meet the
ambitious
but crucial climate targets in the 10
years to come
thank you very much for your attention
thank you very much mario stephanie i
was wondering if you can tell us a
little bit about
the challenges that you have faced in
trying to mainstream
this climate goal all across foundations
and how do you think the european
climate
can help you well i think it was a good
momentum
and foundations were really ready to
integrate
this cross-cutting issue that is climate
because climate is has an impact on all
the areas of foundation
where they are working on could be
education gender
housing migration health food systems
and many others so this is really it was
a good momentum and yes and the answer
was very positive
but we have to expand we only have 130
and are targeted to its thousands of
foundations not only in europe
but across the world so the european
climate pact
is a really good kickoff for her to help
us
to put this philanthropic
climate pledge within a wider framework
and to
initiate collaboration with many other
sectors
thank you so much maria stefan i hope
that you can actually reach out to all
those many foundations
that are not just part of this pledge
but i am sure they will be happy to join
thank you so much for being here today
with us thank you i would like to go now
to emmanuel how are you emmanuel good
morning
good morning from berlin hi how are you
well tell me a little bit about yourself
um what is your pledge
at the european climate pact and how do
you think the path can help you to
achieve that pledge
yeah i'm the founder and ceo of ecoworks
and i worked
in my entire professional life in
developing technologies to
reach net zero and echoworx now
works on solutions technological
solutions
to renovate buildings to net zero
as you know we have 220 million
homes in the eu waiting for renovation
and it would be great if most of them or
even all of them would be renovated to
net zero
so what we do is actually to build a new
envelope a new building around the old
building
and then we enable the building to
produce more energy on the roof with
solar panels
and heat pumps than the tenants need for
hot water for heating for electricity
but it's not only about like net zero
challenge it's also about affordability
so we need a new industry like
as big as the car industry to create
this new industry
and actually this industry could be
about
saving emissions and make business and
profit
in saving emissions and this is a this
is a great challenge
and this is also a european challenge we
were from the beginning
a european startup funded by climate
kick
and also a lot of ideas coming from all
over europe
making money by saving emissions i am
sure many people are very happy to hear
that's actually possible and it actually
is
i was wondering you as a businessman um
and also
coming from a startup which is a small
company what are the challenges that you
face
in this work to wear a more
climate-friendly construction
uh considering that this is one of the
big challenges that we have ahead in
europe and also this part that you were
mentioning about the question of the
social aspect that we've been talking
about also with executive vice president
franklin vermont yeah the um
one big challenge for us is um to really
change the construction industry and
make it more digital and industrialize
uh the construction industry but also
it's a social challenge because
we actually do not only create a digital
product
we are actually changing the ways people
live
and we have to convince the tenants that
this renovation
these renovation packages are actually
good for them
and how to use these new homes and how
actually to make these homes
more um attractive also for for the
people
and which now for example live in fuel
poverty so they they don't have money
to heat their homes so this is a big not
only an economic challenge to get
funds and investors but also a social
challenge thank you so much manuel for
your work and
good luck in the in the coming years in
in making sure that we have
more climate-friendly houses all across
europe and thank you so much to
all the uh the the people who presented
the pledges today
with us thank you so much for joining us
it's been a pleasure talking to you
today thank you
now let's have a look and read some of
the pledges that we got
from you i'm seeing that many of you are
going to talk to your friends about
climate change
it's very important to to raise
awareness repair and reuse is also an
option that has been
voted by many of you walk or cycle more
i think that's very important i do it
myself
um and also good food waste that's very
i'm sure that
massimo portugal will be very happy to
hear that you are planning on cutting a
food waste
also wear cloth that lasts more and eat
seasonal and need
more plants thank you so much for your
answers and for
um being here today uh being part of
this conversation that we're having
throughout the morning now i'm sure that
our colleagues from count has seen will
be very happy to help you to achieve
all these pledges that you have shared
with us so make sure that you check
their website now the climate pact is
nothing without you and every action
counts
we all have a role to play if you want
to join um
make sure that you check our website the
european climate pact
website where you will find all the
information about how to become
a climate pact ambassador or to present
your pledge
you should also check our satellite
events that are going to be organized by
our stakeholders or you can organize one
yourself
if you have a topic you might you would
like to uh to
organize an event about and if you want
to stay informed about everything that's
coming up you can also subscribe to the
climate action
newsletter and stay tuned for the more
many ways in which
you can join the pact in 2021
now as we come to the end i want to
thank
all our guests the climate pact
ambassadors for the incredibly inspiring
moving stories thank you so much guys
thank you so much to our panelists for
their work to build a more climate
friendly society thank you so much
and thank you alex for your art it was
such a beautiful way to summarize
today's ideas to change the world
thank you alex and thank you of course
executive vice president franz
timmermans for being
with us today and of course thank you
everyone behind the cameras who made
this show possible
thank you everyone and of course i want
to thank you for joining us today for
your participation
and your enthusiasm it was great talking
to you
and for the many of you uh the next
weeks are going to be all about
celebrating christmas and the end of the
year
now over the past few months 15 young
europeans have been sharing ideas and
tips on how to be more sustainable as
part
of the ding dong challenge so before we
close the program
we have a very special christmas
challenge for you from
anna now stay safe save the planet and
have a merry sustainable christmas
hi everyone anna masilda one of the 15
dingdong challenge ambassadors
i'm italian but i live in portugal in
beautiful syndra
and together with my fellow ambassadors
here in portugal and in greece lithuania
belgium and germany we've been
challenging young europeans
to implement small changes in their
daily life to adopt a more sustainable
lifestyle
the dinner challenge has been a great
learning experience i already work in
the sustainability field
and online i share daily tips and tricks
about this topic
but the dignity challenge gave